[Música]
a escala en parís
braulio moro
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio francia internacional
en colaboración con france24 en español
racismo antisemitismo terrorismo
populismo son algunas de las amenazas
que hoy acechan a la democracia a nivel
mundial a eso se podría agregar también
el separatismo islamista que cualquier
ente del apocalipsis' también parece
estar rodeando a las democracias
notablemente en francia para hablar de
esta problemática de este cóctel
político cultural y social
invitamos en nuestros estudios a michel
wieviorka profesor de la escuela de
altos estudios en ciencias sociales en
francia uno de los sociólogos más
conocidos del mundo y que acaba de
publicar su último libro por una
democracia de combate mi servidor está
bienvenido a esta escala en parís
gracias por acompañarnos es un placer
estar acá el presidente manuel macro me
presentó recientemente lo que él
denomina su estrategia para luchar
contra el separatismo islamista entre
otras cosas ha hablado concretamente de
una cosa que llama mi atención que
basarse en el patriotismo red
qué opinión le merece el discurso del
patriotismo republicano bueno son
palabras fuertes patriotismo republicano
la verdad es que el discurso habla de
cosa muy razonable lo que propone el
presidente y razonable la necesidad de
introducir patriotismo y republicano es
para combatir el frente nacional es para
combatir la extrema derecha o la de o
para seducir la derecha
norma normal entonces no me gusta la
palabra separatismo que no es la buena
no me gusta estas palabras un poco
extrema patriotismo y el tema es cómo
hacer que hay menos terrorismo islámico
cómo hacer que hay menos realismo en un
país como francia es un arte respecto el
presidente por ejemplo ha dicho que uno
de los factores que podrían explicar
esta polarización este aumento del
separatismo islamista él dice es el
pasado colonial de francia con el que la
república francesa no acaba de saldar
sus cuentas sabemos precisamente que
estuvo presente invierno aunque estuvo
presente en áfrica poco se habla de la
utilización del napalm
antes de los americanos de los eeuu en
áfrica es esto lo que explica una parte
de esta resurgencia de esta emergencia
de un separatismo tan radical que a
veces recurre al terrorismo bueno la
francia fue un país de colonización y es
un país donde la de colonización no fue
tan perfecta fue muy difícil el más
importante fue la guerra de ayer y ah
pero hoy ya eso es muy lejos de nosotros
los jóvenes que viven en francia no son
la fruta directa del colonialismo hay
mucho que ver pero tiene que ver también
con la crisis de los suburbios la
devolvió con el tema del desempleo con
el tema del racismo con el tema de las
discriminaciones con muchas cosas que no
son únicamente las de colonización pero
el colonialismo pesa mucho en el en el
imaginario francés y en la vida de la
gente
michel diego entre los elementos que
plantean el presidente manuel macro para
luchar contra este separatismo islamista
el habla de la necesidad de reforzar el
trabajo en las escuelas en investigación
desarrollar el árabe y aquí me permito
hacer el puente con el libro que usted
acaba reciente publicar te decíamos
lleva por título por una democracia
radical en el que usted insiste es
necesario que las ciencias humanas las
ciencias sociales retomen una parte de
la actividad de las responsabilidades
que han perdido de las cuales se han
alejado y que implica que no reconocen
no han sabido adaptarse a la evolución
de la sociedad bueno el caso francés es
extrema no es el único en el mundo las
ciencias sociales eran el centro del
mundo en los años 60 o 70 yo he conocido
gente que viene de todo el mundo para
escuchar a los grandes a burga de vida a
fútbol a la com
se apuran za y tan muchos otros y
después eso se acabó el mundo ha
cambiado y los franceses las ciencias
sociales franceses un poco arrogantes o
los ingleses y parroquial un poco
provincial un poco incapaz de pensar el
cambio mundial es un tema muy importante
hoy ya cuando se trata de terrorismo de
racismo o de muchas otras cosas o de la
epidemia de kobe donde están muchas
cosas no se escucha mucho los cientistas
sociales se escuchan otros se escuchan
los que hacen sondeos los periodistas se
escucha y otra cosa negacionistas
también sí exactamente y lo que pasa
también es otro aspecto de de las
dificultades de la ciencia social las
ciencias sociales no fueron todas pero
fue muchas de izquierda hoy a la vida
intelectual es mucho más en francia por
lo menos a la derecha la las personas
las más conocidas hoy ya
son de derecha o de extrema derecha o de
casi extremadura y por eso el poder no
se apoya sobre la ciencia social no le
escucha no se interesa a lo que nos lo
podemos hacer y decir y la verdad es que
tomando decisiones hombre el cambio en
la educación en cambio en las relaciones
internacionales y el peso de la historia
lo que usted dice sobre la de colonizar
todo eso no se escucha mucho los
cientistas sociales o los historiadores
o los politólogos y por eso me parece
que es una un error es mucho útil de
saber lo que pueden decir la ciencia
social ya este propósito precisamente
por una democracia radical habla es una
especie de radiografía social de
trayectoria de lo que ha sucedido en
francia no sólo en francia pero sobre
todo en francia en los últimos 50 o 60
años además de esta evolución que usted
observa de la intelectualidad de los
científicos hacia la derecha cuál sería
el principal cambio al cual la
democracia no ha sabido responder
este país bueno el mundo ha cambiado la
sociedad ha cambiado y la democracia no
es muy capaz de decirlo y de hacer cosas
fuerte en frente de ciertos problemas el
desempleo las individualidades que son
crecientes en todo el mundo en todo el
mundo
el tema también del separatismo si se
habla del independentismo que hace con
cuando una parte de un país si yo quiero
estaría difícil el terrorismo y es decir
problemas que son nuevos porque son a
veces una mezcla de problemas internos
al país y de problemas de fuera la
democracia tiene dificultades también
porque el cuadro de la vida de nuestra
vida hoy ya es global
hoy ya hablamos por todo el mundo que
habla español pero la democracia es
capaz de funcionar en el cuadro nacional
estado nación del estado nación o local
entonces hay muchísimas dificultades y
necesitamos nuevas capacidades de de
hacer cosas democráticamente y eso es
muy importante el segundo punto es que
hoy hay un deseo de justicia social
de calidad y de democracy muy fuerte en
el mundo pero no hay las respuestas de
los sistemas políticos que necesitan los
sistemas políticos los actores políticos
no son al nivel de las expectativas del
mundo a este propósito uno de los temas
que surge en estas nuevas situaciones
precisamente un nuevo crecimiento
desarrollo del llamado populismo que
usted aborda en su libro precisamente en
este sentido hace usted también
referencia al populismo por ejemplo que
se desarrolló que se desarrolló perdón
en américa latina a mediados del siglo
pasado con perón en argentina con gulag
en brasil hoy sabemos existen nuevas
figuras del populismo notablemente el
presidente donald trump jair bolsonaro
en brásil
erdogán en turquía por no citar sino
algunos cuál sería la diferencia si es
que la hay entre uno y otro caso de
populista bueno me gusta esta pregunta
porque yo hablo de neo populismo para
que se entiende bien que hay una
diferencia entre los régimen de américa
latina por ejemplo y lo que pasa hoy a
los populismo
no son todos pero en la más importante
parte de derecha y de extrema derecha
los populismos no son en favor de la
apertura de los países de la d son para
que se serán relacionista y si mucho
muere no es populismo o los neo
populismo de hoy ya tienen discursos muy
contradictorios que que no funcionan
bien cuando llegan al poder y son muy
notorios pero muy nacionalistas muy
nacionalista tal vez más que en otros
momentos en el mundo entonces es la
misma familia claramente pero los
discursos tienen mucho que ver con no
aceptamos la globalización eso es
reciente el populismo de hoy ya dice que
los problemas de inmigración son muy
importantes
eso no era parte del discurso populista
de ciertamente pero no que decía
entonces y entonces el populismo es
diferente pero lo más importante en mi
análisis es que el peor no es el
populismo el peor es cuando el populismo
no funciona más como un mito como manera
de solucionar de manera alternativa como
alternativa los problemas cuando es un
discurso es un discurso que el amor no
me gusta pero es un discurso que no
funciona mucho el problema es que cuando
llega al poder o con las 7
cerca del poder el populismo no puedes
más funcionar no puede decir vamos a
hacer los mismos y cambiar ganó tu
cambio a su vez el mid y el grandes el
populismo como un mito
explorer y viene el fascismo y viene la
violencia o tal vez la socialización el
autoritarismo o tal vez la disolución
del pópulo entonces para mí lo
importante es lo que viene después del
populismo el populismo nos dice algo
como algo va a ocurrir después
pero qué va a ocurrir eso es el problema
mi servidor que estamos casi llegando al
final de la emisión una última pregunta
yo quisiera hacerle la democracia por
naturaleza es imperfecta pero además
vemos que hoy en día a veces para luchar
por la democracia se restringen derechos
está por ejemplo la cuestión del crimen
de solidaridad para luchar contra la
migración está la cuestión del estado de
emergencia permanente muy brevemente
significa esto que ahora la democracia
para avanzar para vivir en democracia
hay que restringir los derechos bueno
eso es lo que piensa en todo lo que
dicen que hay que introducir mensuras de
excepción hay que reducir el poder de la
justicia o el poder del parlamente y que
el poder ejecutivo tiene un espacio
mucho más amplio pero la democracia no
es eso no se puede salvar la democracia
con mensuras que no son democráticas o
durablemente es el primer punto el
segundo punto es que la democracia es el
único sistema en el mundo que se conoce
hoy ya que permite dos cosas de un lado
de definir el cuadro general
de la vida colectiva que puede ser una
nación o una república poco importa un
país digamos y del otro lado de
transformar los problemas los conflictos
los temas que surge en la vida colectiva
de transformar los problemas en debate y
en conflicto institucionalizados si
puedo hablar es decir de discutir por
ejemplo mucho interesado el tratamiento
en los estados de la colombia de
colombia pues estamos llegando ya
lamentablemente al final de esta emisión
no me queda sino agradecerle a michel
wieviorka profesor de la escuela de
altos estudios en ciencias sociales en
francia autor de este nuevo libro que
publica que se llama por una democracia
radical su presencia en esta escala en
parís gracias michelle su empresa y a
ustedes muchas gracias por su presencia
[Música]